our continuing series a more perfect
union aims to show us that what unites
us as Americans is far greater than what
divides us today we look at a harmonious
connection through music more than
127,000 people reportedly slept in New
York City's municipal shelters last year
countless more slept on the streets the
homeless population is often overlooked
but Michelle Miller introduces us to one
man who's paying it forward Michelle
good morning good morning Chris leemy
says he never paid much attention to the
homeless around him but when he decided
to try a musical experiment playing his
guitar on the street that all changed
and so did his perspective this might be
the most unlikely duet ever one chrisley
me a 29 year old Wall Street banker the
other John Glenn a veteran living on the
streets of New York City doing it I'm
this Chris right here at 14th Street one
day and stopped biostat how you doing
can I get you anything you need
something what can I do for you that's a
great opener it's great
li me who has a budding side career as a
musician started playing with the
homeless as a way to try out new songs
he'd work out the music and they keep
any tips
it started as okay I'm going to test
these ideas and then I talked to these
people wow I can really identify with
them he could identify because Li me was
quietly battling obsessive-compulsive
disorder which he says nearly derailed
his life
I was sleeping an hour at night and I
was couldn't walk outside unless I did
certain things it was a feeling of
isolation that he discovered haunted the
homeless as well being out here is not
easy I have people I know all my life
and I've known many years they didn't
across the other side of the street when
they see me that hurts my heart and
someone just know me from anywhere to
stop and says hey how you doing what can
I do for you means god I won't stop
crying because I get really I'm I feel
because it means a lot so how do you
guys know each other oh you're sisters
oh my gosh
so Lemmy has made it a point to get to
know the homeless before doing this I
was definitely one who just walked right
by you know I didn't stop and talk to
homeless people I didn't give them any
money but I think what if this has
showed me is that a lot of these
individuals just want someone to talk to
I can't tell you how many times I've
heard
oh I've sat in Union Square for a month
and I've talked to three people it
sounds like they're your therapy yeah
absolutely
I've learned so much from the homeless
population and you know I feel very
lucky now leemy has made this less about
him and more about the people he meets
he started a campaign called he plays
for me to raise awareness and money for
a population that is so little and he's
included some of the homeless in his
music videos how is your music gotten
better as a result
I think it's opened my perspective a new
song coming out it's called hole ground
and the entire premise of that song is
Brazilian and that is something I
learned from the homeless community he's
met countless people with countless
stories and he considers some of them
true friends including a man named his
son I was sitting next to his son and
this woman walked up and said sir can I
buy you a cup of coffee and he said no
thank you and she walked away and he
turned to me he was like did you hear
that she called me sir and he was really
excited about that so you never know the
impact what do you encourage everyone
watching to do
say hello to say hi you'd be shocked at
what you'd learn
[Music]
well because much of the money has come
in in the form of tips on the street
Lina doesn't know exactly how much money
he's actually raised but he says it's
probably more than twenty thousand
dollars yeah yeah mind you have the
humans of New York project you know
we'll just want someone to talk to
love stories and sometimes the stories
just you have no idea how they may
impact you and I think that's really
truly his message Michelle thank thank
you